Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P. In the aftermath
of another horrible holiday weekend of more
mass shootings in the United States. Radical,
repugnant, ridiculous. Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE
is taking out an old toy from the bag of toys. I
guess anti-depressants are to blame for the mass
shootings. A voicemail about that. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: To Marjorie Taylor GREENE tweet about
antidepressants. Now, certain anti-depressants
being the problem. I mean, you know, obviously,
since she's a doctor, she knows best. But
there's a real good way they're complaining
about mental illness, real way to handle it.
Let's take a bunch of people off their meds
and see how they cope and see what happens.
I'm sure all the problem is magically solved.
No more shooting. I mean stuff. Unbelievable. This
woman should be medicated. Seriously, somebody.
Somebody needs to diagnose professional help.
Speaker 1: Okay. Yes. So starting to meander a
bit. But the caller correctly assesses Marjorie
Taylor GREENE has again linked. And by again,
I mean others have done it. I don't know if this
is the first time she's done it or not. She is
linking antidepressants to mass shootings. And
unfortunately, this is one of those things where
it starts to be repeated uncritically and people
just seem to lose their ability to think. And one
of the things that if you really want to study,
whether antidepressants cause people to commit
mass shootings, you would probably be able to set
up such an experiment. And I'd have to think about
the best way to do it. It's not been done. And
unfortunately, you can't really just say, hey,
if some shooters have been on antidepressants,
we have to blame the antidepressants. In fact,
it could be that those already identified as
struggling in certain ways or diagnosed for
certain conditions which might predispose them to
violence, are then put on antidepressants. And the
anti-depressants are a a correlation and not at
all a causation. It would sort of be like saying,
hey, you know, we're noticing I'm making this up,
okay. But imagine that we said I'm noticing that
the people who have heart attacks are often on
blood thinners at a higher rate than the general
population. Maybe the blood thinners cause the
heart attack. Then you have to step back and say,
well, hold on a second. If the blood thinners
are being prescribed to a group at higher risk of
heart attack, we have to consider whether it is a
correlation that is not a causation, that there is
a lot of confounding factor. And in fact, without
the blood thinners, maybe that group would have
an even higher rate of heart attack. I'm making
that up. I don't know if that phenomenon exists,
but it's an important one to think about when
we talk about the antidepressant thing. If
antidepressants cause mass shootings, would
we want to know that? Of course we would.
Why wouldn't we want to know that? There is no
such evidence at this time. And Alex, this is Alex
Jones level stuff. Alex Jones has talked about
that. Others have talked about it again as part
of this concerted effort to talk about everything
other than guns when it comes to mass shootings.
We have a tremendous bonus show for you today.
Producer Pat is back from Hawaii. He will tell us,
did he see Tulsi Gabbard while there and also
what was he up to? I am very curious to hear
about it. I've never been to the 50th state
of the United States, but I would love to go.
We're going to hear from Pat. We will also talk
about a growing problem in the United States
that in many other parts of the world is not
really a problem. The lack of public restrooms,
including in our very own New York City. Okay. We
will talk about all of that and more on the bonus
show. Sign up at join Pacman dot com. Oh, the.
Speaker 2: Bonus show where you want to make
money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Well, easy there. Sign up
at join pacman dot com. You'll get access to
the bonus show. You can use the coupon code.
Big voting 22 to get a discount. And
we will see you then or tomorrow.